All right.
I'm,
I'm really kind of hoping that at least
30% of you will be severely unhappy with
this lecture.
So,
because,
and maybe that's wrong,
I'll find out afterwards.
This is a very,
this dimension of personality.
Agreeableness is one of the dimensions
that most particularly differentiate men
and women and obviously the differences
or similarities between men and women is
a matter of hot debate in our society.
Um,
and,
and I want it run through the
science that's associated with that.
And then,
well,
I guess then we'll see what,
what we conclude.
No,
you remember that the big five were
derived from a statistical analysis of the
content of language.
Hey,
that's kind of interesting because it
means that in so far as any psychological
theory in the history of psychology has
been a theoretical with the possible
exception of intelligence,
um,
research,
which was also the Iq is
also derived statistically,
um,
it was derived by golden or
it was initially theorized
by golden in some sense
back in the late 18 hundreds.
But what Golden Thought of as Eminence
bears very little relationship to what
the psychometric,
what the psychometricians
measure as intelligence.
So intelligence is a statistical construct
or Iq is a statistical construct and
the big five traits are
statistical constructs.
And what that means is that
there are theoretical presumptions
that went into their derivation,
but it's very difficult to think of
them as political because the first
hypothesis was only that
the fundamental dimensions of personality
would be reflected in the language
English to begin with.
But then other languages as the
research progressed around the world,
it's very difficult for me to
understand that as a political theory.
You know?
Cause if scientific findings
have political implications,
then you have to wonder if the biases
of the researchers put the political
implications into the data
before revealing them is data.
But it's very difficult to argue that.
I think with regards to trait theories,
the other thing that happened with
trait theories is that the statistical
analysis suggested their existence.
It wasn't until after the traits
were reasonably well identified.
And this really started to kick in in the
90s that we started to under stand the
potential biological basis.
And,
and even the nature,
the descriptive nature of the traits
at the aspect level now where you
differentiate the big five into 10,
there's still aspects that
we don't know much about.
We don't know,
like we don't really understand the
difference between politeness and
compassion.
We know that liberals are
more compassionate than,
than conservatives.
And conservatives are
more polite than liberals.
And we think that politeness is
somehow associated with the tendency of
conservatives to follow social rules.
But that's about,
I would say that's about all we know now.
We don't even know how much difference
there will turn out to be between polite
politeness and compassion.
But were there are ongoing studies
trying to understand the covariates and
correlates of the aspects.
And the same is true of the traits.
Um,
there was a lot of argument about
openness when it first was discovered
statistically.
Some people like Hans Isaac who formulated
some of the early three dimensional
models of personality and
that was extroversion,
neuroticism and psychotic racism,
which he thought would
predict the proclivity towards
schizophrenia but actually
turned out to be composed of low
agreeableness and low conscientiousness.
Isaac didn't even think that
openness was a reasonable trait.
He thought it was mostly captured by Iq.
And actually that seems to be the case
to some degree because if you divide
openness into intellect and
into openness to experience,
it looks like Iq loads on intellect or
at least the nonverbal part of Iq loads
on intellect where the verbal part of
Iq tends to load more on openness and
sodas,
openness to experience
and so does creativity.
But this is all discovered after the fact.
So now one of the things that's
happened as a consequence of parsing out
personality into the big five traits and
also using other traits schemas is that
it's quite clear that there
are differences between
the sexes or if you like
differences between the genders.
Now this is a thorny problem and
it's thorny for a number of reasons.
One reason is that it's a dogmatic
assumption proposition of social
constructionists that gender
differences are socially constructed.
First of all,
they separate out the idea of sex,
which you could think of as bio biological
sex you could think of is chromosomal
sex.
I presume that's one thing,
but gender,
that's a whole different thing and gender
is the manner in which men and women
present themselves to the world
in terms of differences in,
well,
anything that you can measure that's
above the fundamentally biological level.
Maybe you could say anything
above the chromosomal difference.
Okay.
I don't exactly know where the
distinction is supposed to be made between
biological sex and gender.
It's not a simple thing to understand,
but the proposition still obtains that
if there are differences between men and
women at the level of
phenotypic manifestation,
then they're socially constructed.
The problem with that is that it seems
to be wrong and not just a little bit
wrong,
but wrong,
right to the core.
And one of the things that I would like
to propose to you is that the social
constructionists only
have theory on their side.
I don't believe they have any data
to support their claims whatsoever.
Now,
I also think that they wouldn't accept
the sorts of things that I'm going to
talk to you about as data,
but that's a whole different argument.
MMM.
I don't really understand how
it's possible for people in an,
in the modern world to reject scientific
claims given that almost everything
they do in their day to day life that
has anything to do with technology
whatsoever,
depends for its function on the
validity of the scientific theories that
underpin the technology.
So what that means is that people who
treat scientific data as if it's just
another form of information,
socially constructed information certainly
don't behave like that if you follow
them around in the actual world.
Now here is the proposition
about agreeable.
That's,
I don't know if this is
the case because as I said,
there's lots of things we don't
understand about the big five dimensions,
but this is how I've worked it out
for my own understanding and it's in
accordance with the data in so
far as I can determine that.
Right.
Agreeableness seems to
be the dimension between,
we certainly know agreeable people were
empathic and compassionate and polite.
We know less about disagreeable people,
although we know that they're
more likely to be male.
Now you could associate being disagreeable
with being more callous and more
harsh and more selfish in that if you
had to bargain with someone who's low in
agreeableness,
they would fight harder for their side
of the equation than someone high in
agreeableness would fight for.
There's now,
there's a couple of things about human
beings that that aren't considered
sufficiently.
I believe in so far as we conceptualize
human personality and one is that humans
are unbelievably maternal,
both genders.
They have to be because our babies
are born for a mammal of our size.
That gestation period should be two years,
not nine months,
and so what that means is that babies,
human babies are already born and you
can tell that because you know like
ungulates deer,
think gears an ungulate,
it doesn't matter.
Pretty much as soon as they're born,
they can stagger up on their
legs and start to run around.
Whereas a human baby isn't doing that
till 15 months or 13 months or 17 months
or depending on the baby,
you know?
So,
and babies are pretty much completely
helpless at birth and so they need a
tremendous amount of care.
And then because we have such a large
cortex and because we're so behaviorally
plastic,
we have an extraordinarily long
dependence and development period.
You know,
it's a minimum,
it depends on the culture,
but it's a minimum of 13 years and it
can certainly extend far beyond that and
does in cultures where there's a
tremendous amount of inculcation of
information.
So we also know that maternal
behavior is very common among mammals.
I mean the very definition of mammal
in some sense has to do with maternal
behavior because mammals,
well they bear live young and they
produce milk with their warm blooded.
There's some other characteristics.
So,
so the ability to care for helpless
frequently upset,
dependent
creatures for a very long period of time
is part of our behavioral repertoire.
Now then you might wonder,
are there individual differences in the
degree to which people are maternal?
And I think that's captured,
at least in part with agreeableness,
it makes sense because on the
positive pole of agreeableness,
that's where you get warmth and compassion
and empathy and a desire to care for
others and and self sacrifice.
I would say one of the things will
will show later is the agreeable.
This is negatively correlated with income,
which is exactly what you'd expect if
you were negotiating with someone who was
self sacrificing because they're not
going to put forward their side of the
power equation as forcefully
as someone who is disagreeable.
So,
but you know,
in order to raise a baby you
have to be self sacrificing.
There is no two ways about it.
You might find that
rewarding and worthwhile,
but I don't believe there is a parent
who actually becomes a good parent who
doesn't put their child's welfare first.
And I think that's
particularly true of mothers,
particularly in the
first year after birth.
It's probably true right
up to the age of three,
but I think it's virtually
undeniably true for the first year.
Okay.
The question is,
is that
reflected in personality traits?
Now,
the other thing about people that
it's worthwhile recognizing is that
we're hunters.
All right.
People aren't coniferous are pretty
good at bringing down big game.
It's reasonable to suppose that the
reason that there aren't as many large
animals in North America as there are
in Africa is because when human beings
came into North Africa,
North America,
15,000 years ago,
they killed all of them.
They killed all the mammoths,
they killed all the giant bears,
they killed all the cats,
they killed all the,
I think there were camels,
maybe can't remember precisely.
Anyways,
there was a very large array of very large
mammals and they started to disappear
pretty damn quickly after the period of
time where people migrated into North
America.
Now,
one of the theories is that in Africa,
the animals and the people co evolved
so that the animals and the people had
fallen into some sort of mutual
stability.
But in North America,
that wasn't the case at all.
They don't,
I don't think it was that easy to
bring down a mammoth with a sphere.
So it was very destructive of
people to do what they did.
But it also says volumes about
what human beings are like.
And it's certainly the case
that a nontrivial proportion
of the human population
still hunts.
And they'll do that for leisure,
which is something that's very difficult
for people who aren't countries to
understand.
And they're almost all men,
which I don't think will
come as a surprise to anyone.
So I think that predatory aggression
is on the other side of agreeableness,
and we also know that the best predictor
of whether or not you're going to be in
prison is low agreeableness.
Now,
low conscientiousness also helps,
but the fundamental marker of antisocial
behavior in so far as it's captured by
the big five personality markers
seems to be low agreeableness.
And that you might also say,
given that men are less
agreeable than women,
that that's part of the reason why
men are much more likely
to be in prison than women.
I think it's between,
okay,
I think it's 91% of
incarcerated criminals are male,
but I'm certain that it's
above 80% I believe it's 91%.